[Music]
thanks for joining us guys here at the
playstation competition center for more
coverage on tekken 7.
i'm rip joined with markman today we're
going to be talking about one of the
things that people love to do in
fighting games
combos specifically we're gonna be
talking about how to juggle your
opponent in tekken 7.
now we'll construct a basic and simple
combo that you can use in most offensive
situations
the combo may not do a lot of damage and
may not be hard to execute but you don't
start there
instead we'll get a basic and simple
combo that you can use in all levels of
play
let's jump in there are four important
parts to most checking combos
the starter the combo the screw attack
and the ender
let's break down each part the starter
is a move that knocks the opponent into
the air
or leaves them in trouble state leaving
them vulnerable for follow-up attacks
the movie just saw it's called a hop
kick several characters also have a move
that looks similar to this and most will
launch the opponent
there are also some moves that crumple
the opponent to their knees and strike
them while they're attacking you can
then pop the opponent into the air with
your next hit
let's use king's up forward right kick
as our launcher for this video
once the opponent is in the air you can
now start to add more hits
it is important to know which moves are
viable for combo filler as you extend
your juggle
or your combo will end before you want
it remember the more hits you land in
the juggle the farther it will push away
your opponent
let's use king's down forward right kick
left kick as our jungle for this video
the next goal is to use a screw attack
while the opponent is in the air
this is a unique attack that spins the
opponent around and extends your combo
they are marked by a green spiral symbol
in your move list let's take a look at
king's back right punch left one screw
attack
now let's take a look at the sequence so
far starter
combo screw attack
after an opponent spins to the ground
you're allowed to hit them with one
final move sequence
this is the ender let's use king's
common combo ender the running powerbomb
and now we can do the whole sequence
starter
combo screw attack and the ender
let's check it out at full speed
it can be intimidating to come up with
these combos on your own fortunately in
practice mode tekken has a bunch of
sample combos for all characters
often sample combos will show you some
variations on this combo structure for
you to practice
start at some easy combos and work your
way up from there
now being able to do these combos
doesn't mean you're going to be able to
use it in every situation
tech is a very deep game has a lot of
different places you may have to modify
these combos but now
you know the different pieces of the
combo structure you'll be able to
assemble your own combos in no time
that's it for this episode this tutorial
was made in partnership with the
playstation competition center team
you can sign up for open series
competitions on compete.playstation.com
subscribe to the bne esports channel for
more tutorials and soul calibur 6
content